emotionen ausdrücken
hallo
wie geht es dir heute
wie fühlst du dich
wie fühlst du dich bist du glücklich
bist du glücklich bist du traurig
bist du traurig
oder bist du wütend
heute werden wir lernen gefühle und
emotionen auszudrücken
zunächst sechs wichtige emotionen die du
kennen muss
haupt emotionen
erstens die freude zweitens die
traurigkeit
drittens die überraschung
viertens die furcht 5
der ekel
sechstens die wut die freude die freude
ich bin froh
ich bin froh weil wir heute am strand
sind
die traurigkeit die traurigkeit
ich bin traurig
ich bin traurig weil der teddy bear
kaputt ist
ich bin traurig weil der teddybär kaputt
ist
die überraschung die überraschung
[Musik]
ich bin überrascht ich bin überrascht
ich bin überrascht über das unerwartete
geschenk
die furcht die furcht
ich fürchte mich ich fürchte mich
ich fürchte mich verwehren
der ekel der ekel
wie eklig wie eklig
ich finde gemüse wirklich eklig
die wut die wut
ich bin wütend ich bin wütend ich bin
sehr wütend über die schlechte arbeit
ich bin sehr wütend über die schlechte
arbeit
jetzt andere positive emotionen jetzt
andere positive emotionen das glück
das glück
ich bin glücklich
ich bin sehr glücklich über meine
geburtstagsparty
die begeisterung die begeisterung
ich bin begeistert
ich bin begeistert von meinem neuen
handy
die fröhlichkeit die fröhlichkeit
ich bin fröhlich ich bin fröhlich
ich bin fröhlich weil wir einen schönen
tag zusammen verbracht haben
die hoffnung
die hoffnung ich hoffe ich hoffe
dass die prüfung gut gelaufen ist
ich hoffe dass die prüfung gut gelaufen
ist
der mut der mut
ich bin mutig
wie mutig er ist
der wunsch
ich wünsche ich wünsche
ich wünsche mir ein neues fahrrad
die vorfreude die vorfreude
ich freue mich schon auf den urlaub
andere wörter die ein gefühl ausdrücken
der stolz der stolz wir sind stolz
wir sind stolz wir sind sehr stolz auf
sie wir sind sehr stolz auf sie
das erstaunen das erstaunen
ich bin wirklich erstaunt
ich habe das nicht erwartet ich habe das
nicht erwartet
die zufriedenheit die zufriedenheit
deine prüfung war sehr gut deine prüfung
war sehr gut
sag wer bist du zufrieden
die gelassenheit die gelassenheit
heute bringt mich nicht aus der ruhe
[Musik]
ich bleibe gelassen egal was passiert
die liebe die liebe
ich liebe kuchen ich liebe kuchen
ich liebe dich
aber es kommt auch vor dass man sich
nicht positiv fühlt also
wie kann man negative gefühle ausdrücken
[Musik]
negative gefühle
die angst die angst ich habe angst
ich habe angst ich habe angst lass uns
gehen
ich habe angst lass uns gehen
die störung die störung
ich fühle mich gestört
rauchen stark mich sehr
rauchen statt mich sehr
die langeweile die langeweile
ich langweile mich
ich langweile mich diese lektion ist
wirklich langweilig diese lektion ist
wirklich langweilig
die nervosität
die nervosität ich bin nervös ich bin
nervös ich bin nervös weil ich morgen
die deutschprüfung b1 habe
ich bin nervös weil ich morgen die
deutschprüfung b1 habe und noch viel
lernen muss und noch viel lernen muss
die verlegenheit die verlegenheit
ich bin ganz verlegen
soll ich sie fragen ob ich mit ihnen
spielen darf soll ich sie fragen ob ich
mit ihnen spielen darf die scham die
scham
wie peinlich
schäme mich weil ich das tablett
fallengelassen habe
die schuld die schuld ich fühle mich
schuldig ich fühle mich schuldig ich
fühle mich schuldig weil ich ihr
spielzeug kaputt gemacht habe
ich fühle mich schuldig weil ich ihr
spielzeug kaputt gemacht habe das
bedauern das bedauern
ich bedauere
[Musik]
den unfall bedauere ich sehr
die eifersucht die eifersucht
bis du zufällig eifersüchtig
die frustration die frustration
ich werde nie rechtzeitig fertig sein
ich bin so frustriert
die schüchternheit die schüchternheit
ich bin zu schüchtern ich bin zu
schüchtern
ich bin zu schüchtern um sie um ein date
zu bitten
der hass der hass
ich hasse es das geschirrspülen zu
müssen
ich hasse es das geschirr spülen zu
am meisten hasse ich es das geschirr
spülen zu müssen
am meisten hasse ich es das
geschirrspülen zu müssen
der neid der neid wie macht er das nur
wie macht er das nur ich gönne ihm den
erfolg nicht
ich gönne ihm den erfolg nicht ich
möchte er auch so gut machen können
ich möchte er auch so gut malen kennen
die einsamkeit die einsamkeit
ich bin einsam ich bin einsam
ich habe keine freunde und fühle mich
einsam
also wie fühlst du dich heute
schreibe es in die kommentare
hinterlasse uns einen like und abonniere
unseren kanal bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss